This is 99% invisible. And the code DC. It's a special joint episode between my friend here, Roman Mars. And my friend Andrea Seabruck. It's election season, as you know. And Andrea and I found out we had a lot of the same questions about the political events that are everywhere right now. Questions like, how much of a debate or a press conference
这是《99%隐形》。我是Roman Mars，这是DC。这是一期特别的联合节目，由我和我的朋友Andrea Seabruck共同制作。如你所知，现在是选举季。Andrea和我发现，对于当下随处可见的政治事件，我们有很多共同的疑问。比如，一场辩论或新闻发布会，有多少是真正自发的？又有多少是预先策划好的？
is genuinely spontaneous? And how much is pre-planned? Who designs the theater of politics? Why do speeches and town hall meetings look the way they do? And what message are the campaigns trying to express with their design? To answer some of these questions, we track down two of the most interesting people I've ever talked to in politics. And we ask them for their secrets.
谁在设计政治舞台？为什么演讲和市政厅会议看起来是那个样子？竞选团队试图通过他们的设计传达什么信息？为了回答这些问题，我们追踪了两位我所接触过的政治领域中最有趣的人，并向他们询问了其中的秘密。
Secret number one, every campaign has a brand. This is probably not a huge secret to anyone who's paying close attention, but it's more than just the politician himself as a brand is an abstraction that floats on top of the human being that's running for office. So Obama in 2008, it was hope and for Romney right now, I don't know, I can't really put my finger on it. Romney's brand is like a competent businessman who can bring back jobs. That is the message that the campaign is selling
秘密一：每场竞选都有一个品牌。对于那些密切关注的人来说，这可能不是什么大秘密，但这不仅仅是政客本人，品牌是一种抽象概念，漂浮在竞选公职的人之上。比如2008年的奥巴马，那是“希望”；而现在的罗姆尼，我不知道，我真的说不准。罗姆尼的品牌就像是一个能带回就业机会的能干商人。这就是竞选团队正在兜售的信息。
and every detail is arranged to market that brand. The politician's clothes, how he walks, what he says, where he goes, his sense of humor, his wife, his haircut, his watch. Which brings us to secret number two. Every campaign has a team of people who are in charge of making every event fit that brand. They're called the advanced team. From campaign headquarters, they're given a location, a date, a type of event, and a
每一个细节都是为了营销那个品牌而安排的。政客的衣服、走路的方式、说的话、去的地方、幽默感、妻子、发型、手表。这就引出了秘密二：每个竞选团队都有一群人负责让每一场活动都符合那个品牌。他们被称为“先遣团队”。从竞选总部出发，他们会得到一个地点、一个日期、一种活动类型和一张机票。
plane ticket. Donnie Fowler is a long time advanced guy. He worked for Bill Clinton, El Gorge, John Kerry, Barack Obama. I'm so he's a Democrat. Yes, very much Democrat. And Fowler says that for every campaign event, there's something you have to have on the stage, but it's a different thing in every place. Whether it's the flag or in Iowa, the hay, bail, or the coal miner standing behind you in Ohio,
Donnie Fowler是一位资深的先遣人员。他曾为比尔·克林顿、阿尔·戈尔、约翰·克里、巴拉克·奥巴马工作。所以他是民主党人？是的，非常坚定的民主党人。Fowler说，对于每一场竞选活动，舞台上都必须有某种东西，但在不同的地方，东西是不一样的。无论是旗帜，还是在爱荷华州的干草捆，或者是站在你身后的俄亥俄州煤矿工人，
or the beach, if you're in Florida, the naval yard if you're in Virginia. So you won't local color, you won't find a Americana, and you won't real people. The key, he says, is making the event real people. The key he says is making the event look genuine. The politician looked more human and good at relating to regular
或者如果你在佛罗里达州就是海滩，在弗吉尼亚州就是海军造船厂。所以你想要当地特色，你想要美国风情，你想要真实的人。他说，关键在于让活动看起来真实。政客看起来更人性化，更善于与普通美国人建立联系。
Americans. So you rarely are going to see even mid-Romney in front of a boardroom with a bunch of white guys in blue suits and red ties. Because even though his background to his benefit, to his credit, is from the corporate
所以你很少会看到米特·罗姆尼出现在一群穿着蓝色西装、打着红色领带的白人男性的董事会前。因为尽管他的背景——这是他的优势，也是他的功劳——来自企业董事会，但当你竞选总统时，那并不是你想选择的形象。
boardroom, that's not the kind of images you want to choose when you're running for president. Now John Ceton, a Republican advanced guy, agrees. Having a veil of hair, corn, reference, or something like that certainly kind of gives you know, makes it clear that you're somewhere rural, so makes it clear that, you know, if it's caucus season, you're an Iowa and sends that message. Seaton worked for Republicans like John McCain, Sarah Palin, Tim Polenti. And that brings us to secret number three. The advanced teams run their campaigns pretty much the same way.
现在，共和党先遣人员John Seaton也表示同意。他说，有干草堆、玉米、参考资料或类似的东西，确实能让你清楚地知道你身处农村，或者如果是在党团会议季节，你就在爱荷华州，并传达出那个信息。Seaton曾为约翰·麦凯恩、萨拉·佩林、蒂姆·波伦蒂等共和党人工作。这就引出了秘密三：先遣团队运作竞选的方式几乎是一样的。
Some are better funded than others, but they're all doing the same thing, marketing their brand day by day event by event. Fowler says the advance team flies into the event location a week or more before a speech or rally. A 20 minute event requires several dozen people, campaign staff, secret service. They start there from zero and work hundreds and hundreds of hours to put together what might be that 20-minute campaign stop. The advanced team is responsible for the staging of the event, from the flowers to the backdrop, to the security and the audience. The first big decision is where to have the event. And that, says Valor, can so easily go wrong.
有些资金比其他团队更充足，但他们都在做同样的事情，日复一日、一场活动接一场活动地营销他们的品牌。Fowler说，先遣团队会在演讲或集会前一周或更早飞抵活动地点。一场20分钟的活动需要几十个人，包括竞选工作人员、特勤局。他们从零开始，花费数百个小时来筹备那20分钟的竞选停留。先遣团队负责活动的布置，从鲜花到背景，再到安保和观众。第一个重大决定是活动地点。Fowler说，这很容易出错。
Like in 2004, when John Kerry went to the key primary state of South to have the event. And that can so easily go wrong. Like in 2004, when John Kerry went to the key primary state of South Carolina to announce his candidacy. Kerry's a Vietnam war hero and he gave his speech before the USS Yorktown,
就像2004年，当约翰·克里前往关键初选州南卡罗来纳州宣布参选时。克里是一位越战英雄，他在“约克城号”航空母舰前发表了演讲，
a massive aircraft carrier. Which at the time seemed like a good idea. Everyone in America knows it's not fair. The crowd was tiny. And especially in front of a huge aircraft carrier, a tiny crowd looked even tiny. And fair, once and for all.
那是一艘巨大的航空母舰。当时这看起来是个好主意。美国人都知道这不公平。人群非常稀少。特别是在巨大的航空母舰前，稀少的人群看起来更显渺小，一劳永逸地显露出来。
There's a big lesson in this one, says Fowler. Don't put the candidate in a situation where he looks diminished because you can't build a crowd. Same as the Romney economic speech this year where he put it in a football stadium and there was only a few thousand people that looked like nobody showed up to hear Romney talk about the economy. I want to thank the folks at the Ford field for making this space available for us. I guess we had a hard time finding a large enough place to meet and this certainly is. Now the Republican advanced guy,
Fowler说，这其中有一个很大的教训。不要把候选人置于让他看起来显得渺小的境地，因为你无法聚集人群。就像今年罗姆尼的经济演讲，他把它放在一个足球场里，结果只有几千人，看起来就像没人来看罗姆尼谈论经济一样。我想感谢福特球场的人们为我们提供这个场地。我想我们很难找到足够大的地方来开会，而这里确实够大。现在，共和党先遣人员Seaton也谈到了那次罗姆尼的演讲，他也说选择一个太大的场地可能是灾难性的。
Seaton, also talked about that Romney speech and he too says choosing a venue that's too large can be disastrous. You know immediately before the candidate even takes the stage, you're going to have people tweeting and blogging about how you know candidate X clearly doesn't have very much support in this county because his venue is basically empty. And then remember, those week clauses, the camera's pan of the empty stadium will be played over and over and over again. Romney's campaign couldn't even fill all the chairs in the audience.
你知道，在候选人上台之前，人们就会在推特和博客上说，候选人X在这个县显然没有多少支持，因为他的场地基本上是空的。然后记住，那些弱点，摄像机扫过空荡荡体育场的画面会被一遍又一遍地播放。罗姆尼的竞选团队甚至无法坐满观众席上的椅子。
Secret number four is a corollary to this. Every campaign these days sends out well spies, I guess you could call them, to every one of their opponents events. In politics, they're called trackers to see. We have been generating more and more trackers from the other campaigns. You don't want to give them anything to use.
秘密四是这一点的推论。如今，每个竞选团队都会派遣——我想你可以称他们为间谍——到对手的每一场活动中。在政治上，他们被称为“追踪者”。我们看到其他竞选团队派出的追踪者越来越多。你不想给他们任何可以利用的东西。
On the visual side, they'll offer to Canada. So here's the half secret. The advanced staff of one candidate often becomes friendly with the trackers of their opponent. Morning Ralph. Morning Sam. I mean, hey, they're in the same line of work. There's each other everywhere. It's their life. Well, better luck next time, Ralph. Oh, sure. You can't win them all, you know.
在视觉方面，他们会提供给候选人。所以这就是半个秘密。一个候选人的先遣人员经常会和对手的追踪者变得友好。早上好，Ralph。早上好，Sam。我的意思是，嘿，他们从事的是同一行。他们在到处都能见到对方。这就是他们的生活。好吧，下次好运，Ralph。哦，当然。你不可能赢下每一场，你知道的。
Thanks. Nice day, I Sam. Yep. Good to be alive, Ralph. Secret number five. Everything is staged. I cannot stress this enough. And the longer in advance an event is planned, the more granular that staging becomes. Take the debates, says Fowler. So here's what you're seeing is not an extemporaneous debate between two very smart people.
谢谢。美好的一天，Sam。是的。活着真好，Ralph。秘密五：一切都是安排好的。我怎么强调都不为过。一场活动提前计划的时间越长，那种安排就越细致。以辩论为例，Fowler说。所以你看到的不是两个非常聪明的人之间即兴的辩论。
No, it's an incredibly, finally staged theater. Every little detail about that stage how they're standing is discussed and litigated early. And if you watch carefully, Cecetan, you can tell. Look at how the candidate she can and the presence they have with each other, what they're doing and the other person's talking. Then there are the conventions. Also incredible dramaturgical feats From the message of the speeches to the timing of the balloon drop even the chance of the crowds that seem so spontaneous They're completely pre-planned by the campaign staff Come be bright, come be bright, come on be bright. Seaton says each section of the convention floor
不，这是一场极其精心编排的戏剧。关于舞台的每一个小细节，他们站立的方式，都在早期进行了讨论和争论。如果你仔细观察，Seaton说，你可以看出来。看看候选人之间的互动，他们表现出的存在感，当对方说话时他们在做什么。然后是全国代表大会。这也是令人难以置信的戏剧性壮举，从演讲的内容到气球掉落的时间，甚至连看起来如此自发的群众口号，都是由竞选团队完全预先计划好的。
has a campaign whip who receives instructions passed down from a central planner. And the whips then make sure that their sections are chanting appropriately. Because left to their own devices, a big group can become a big stupid mob. Like at the Republican Convention this year, when a bunch of people started chanting the USA preventing the committee woman from Puerto Rico from
Seaton说，大会会场的每个区域都有一名竞选“鞭策者”，负责接收来自中央规划者的指令。然后，鞭策者会确保他们所在的区域口号喊得恰当。因为如果任由他们自己发挥，一大群人可能会变成一大群愚蠢的暴民。就像今年共和党全国代表大会上，当一群人开始高喊“美国”时，阻止了来自波多黎各的委员会成员
taking a mic. Which actually brings us to secret number six. No matter how carefully the advanced team plans, campaign events can and do go wrong. And the biggest screw-ups, Saseaton, are totally self-inflicted. And then I think everyone remembers Governor Palin doing an interview with Front of Turkey's being being killed. The event was supposed to be a pardoning of a Thanksgiving turkey, Palin's attempt to do a presidential event.
走上麦克风。这实际上引出了秘密六：无论先遣团队计划得多么周密，竞选活动都可能而且确实会出错。Seaton说，最大的失误完全是自找的。我想每个人都记得佩林州长在火鸡被宰杀前接受采访。那次活动本应是感恩节火鸡的赦免仪式，是佩林尝试进行的一次总统级活动。
But when she took questions from reporters, she stood right in front of a slaughtering table. Oh, well, this was me, Dave. I was happy to get to be invited to participate in this. And you know, behind her right now, a man is hoisting live turkeys up into a cone so he can slit their necks and bleed them to death. You see this happening and it's just like there was no one there to say wait a minute
但当她接受记者提问时，她就站在屠宰台前。哦，好吧，这是我，Dave。我很高兴能受邀参加这次活动。你知道，在她身后，一个人正把活火鸡吊进锥子里，这样他就可以割断它们的脖子，让它们流血致死。你看到这一幕发生，就像当时没有人说“等一下，
maybe we should move this interview you know five feet over the left for something. Donnie Fowler remembers a fancy fundraiser for Bill Clinton's 1996 re-election campaign. Harvey Weinstein and Paul Newman were going to introduce President Clinton into this big fundraiser in Connecticut. And I was in charge of telling Paul Newman and Harvey Weinstein when they were going to go up on the stage to welcome President Clinton into the room. And in my little earpiece, I heard, where are you in the program? We're on our way.
也许我们应该把这次采访往左移五英尺或者什么的”。Donnie Fowler记得比尔·克林顿1996年连任竞选的一次豪华筹款活动。Harvey Weinstein和Paul Newman要在康涅狄格州的这场大型筹款活动中介绍克林顿总统。我负责告诉Paul Newman和Harvey Weinstein他们什么时候上台欢迎克林顿总统进入房间。在我的小耳机里，我听到：“你们在流程的哪个环节？我们正在路上。”
And so I went to Mr. Weinstein and Mr. Newman, and I said, gentlemen, it's time for you to go and introduce President into the room. So they stand up and they say how happy they are to be there and they say ladies and gentlemen will you please stand up and welcome President Clinton to the room. The doors in the back of the room opened, the spotlight shown on the doors and in walk Kinny G. and in walk Kenny G. So Harvey Weinstein and Paul Moon would look at me from the stage like, what the heck is going on man. Fowler realized the wrong person had been talking in his earpiece saying,
所以我走到Weinstein先生和Newman先生身边，我说：“先生们，是时候去介绍总统进入房间了。”于是他们站起来，说他们很高兴能来到这里，然后说：“女士们，先生们，请站起来欢迎克林顿总统进入房间。”房间后面的门打开了，聚光灯照在门上，走进来的是Kenny G。走进来的是Kenny G。所以Harvey Weinstein和Paul Newman在台上看着我，心想，这到底是怎么回事，伙计。Fowler意识到耳机里说话的人搞错了，说，
let's get started, we're on our way. He thought it was Clinton's handlerslers but it had been Kenny G's. And that brings us to secret number seven. Everyone traveling with the campaign the advanced team the handlers probably even the candidate ends up loathing the music. So do the reporters. First. Step out of the day! The sort of upbeat, we love America pop song that you come to the stage and you leave the stage and work the rope line with too. Brooks and Duns got this song, Only in America that I think has been used by both parties since President Bush in 2004. The patriotic mix, Satan and Valor, both of them, serious political animals, told us they
“让我们开始吧，我们正在路上。”他以为是克林顿的助手，但其实是Kenny G的助手。这就引出了秘密七：每个随竞选团队旅行的人，先遣团队、助手，甚至可能是候选人本人，最终都会厌恶那些音乐。记者们也是如此。第一步，走出这一天！那种欢快、我们热爱美国的流行歌曲，你上台、下台、在警戒线旁工作时都会用到。Brooks and Dunn的那首《Only in America》，我想自2004年布什总统以来，两党都在使用。爱国混音，Seaton和Fowler，他们两个都是严肃的政治动物，告诉我们他们
do not miss that in the off years. So Satan, Valor, I can't remember who's the Republican and who's the Democrat. It doesn't matter. They're putting on the same show. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Andrea C. Bruck-Lena, Macintosh, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of KALW and the AIA San Francisco. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram,
在非选举年并不会怀念这些。所以Seaton，Fowler，我不记得谁是共和党人，谁是民主党人。这不重要。他们上演的是同一场戏。《99%隐形》本周由Andrea C. Bruck、Lena Macintosh、Sam Greenspan和我Roman Mars制作。我们是KALW和AIA旧金山分会的项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Instagram上，
and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio to the end. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有Spotify，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括很酷的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。广播直到最后。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。